alors on termine la semaine un peu comme
on l'a commencée on parle de ce fameux
des versements qui doit avoir lieu le 18
octobre des eaux usées parce que la
ville veut mais vous le savez effectuer
les travaux luc ferrandez chef de
l'opposition officielle avec demont
reste avec nous tu ferrandez bonsoir
bonsoir bon sûr je rends comprends que
vous non plus c'est pas un plaisir que
de dire oui on y va on a compris
aujourd'hui que vous dites on ne
peut-être pas le choix effectivement là
il ya des choses à faire mais faisons-le
un bon on espère qu'elle fera pas on
espère qu'on le fera plus jamais et pour
plus jamais le faire faudra que le coup
quand tu fais une affaire comme celle là
faudrait que tu es à payer une
compensation équivalente à la nuisance
que tu as créé ce soit partout au canada
d'ailleurs à montréal toronto toutes les
villes de victoria aussi les régions du
québec plus de déversement sans
compensation et de rien avant ça ça veut
dire que la personne qui vont vouloir
faire des versements devraient penser à
deux fois ce matin là même qu'on verse à
une compensation mettons de 50 millions
à la ville de montréal pour ce
déversement alors elle aurait trouvé une
solution en amont et c'est ce qui
devrait avoir lieu là bas couture et
avec cet argent la ville ferait quoi le
prix à payer polluer notre avance et ça
a payé alors prêt puncheur d'abord et
accélérer les travaux de l'usiné
d'ionisation elle peut régler les
problèmes de dégoût croisé qui envoient
des contaminants tous les jours dans le
fleuve violent la question de yad autres
travaux en amont qu'il pourrait payer en
lac saint pierre les décidément qui fait
que plus de perchaudes dans l'axé un
personnel qu'avec la pêche commerciale
dans l'axé un plat sur le lac
saint-pierre contrairement au reste du
fleuve c'est plus tard quand ça stoppe
ses loques les contaminants s'accumulent
qu'on paye compain des travaux là où on
pollue pas dire dans d'autres villes
mais s'apprête géré par le fédéral parce
que là vous êtes arrivé où je vous pose
la question êtes vous arrivé à la
conclusion vous ici que dans le fond on
n'a pas aimé la façon dont le maire a
géré ça il y en eut manque de
transparence dit vous en le chat
dernière minute c mais cela dit là on
n'a pas le choix faut le faire je ne
peux pas me la conclusion qu'on n'a pas
le choix faut le faire parce qu'on est
en reprise et là on n'a pas reçu une
information malheureusement le maire le
dit mon encore aucun document qui nous
dit que c'est soit urgent en soi est
nécessaire de changer des centres et 2
de d'avant ça c'est dans les tuyaux
pourquoi je suis sur ma terre encore où
c'était hier les ingénieurs et on n'a
même pas été consultés pour savoir c'est
une solution internationale de la ville
de montréal on à la direction de
l'environnement jamais été consultés
maintenant les ingénieurs de la ville de
montréal n'ont pas été consultés pour
savoir s'il y avait une solution
alternative donc l'on les vendredis
18h35 à cette heure là vous ne vous ne
vous ne pensez pas comme le maire que
toutes les autres options ont été
explorées mais le maire il y avait un
objectif en tête faire ça en silence
puis faire ce gratuitement en silence le
cerac c'est raté mais il nous est jamais
démontré jamais déposé les documents
qu'ils me disent ainsi impossible de
faire autrement si on arrive à cette
conclusion là il faut au moins que ce
soit pas gratuit il faut qu'on travaille
à l'amélioration du fleuve avec plutôt
que de créer un impact négatif qu'on
crée un impact négatif dans un premier
temps mais positive dans l'avenir c'est
facile vers la gloire on ne peut pas
déverser nos audigou sans qui un coup
voilà peillon c'est fini c'est un chèque
exactement j'accélère des travaux mais
quelque chose oui au moins de saint
brais un coup pour qu'on réfléchisse la
prochaine fois il faut pas juste pour
symboliser clair mais sur statuer si
nécessaire ou pas malheureusement on n'a
pas les documents sous les yeux se faire
en deux avait parlé de victoria
c'est pire ah si oui et plus de ces
primaires mais barcelone déversées dans
la mer aussi bien arrêter de le faire
toronto fait des déversements on a su
que longueuil afin des versements mais
il ya une différence entre des
déversements que son sac les eaux
pluviales comme nous on a fait à
quelques reprises on a des déversements
qui sont liées à des apports de pluies
importants mais le lift les substances
toxiques sont extrêmement dilués et une
purge la peluche qu'on va faire la céda
toxicité pur qu'on envoie dans le fleuve
et ça c'est un coup énorme et c'est pour
ça que l'on peut pas comparer avec
victoria le long convoi le lac
saint-pierre l'océan pacifique moi c'est
deux choses différentes très bien